we're super happy
um
what can i tell you we're just
having a good time looks like jennifer
lopez is having the time of her life
since officially becoming mrs ben
affleck and we're told the newlyweds are
still on cloud nine a source tells e.t
quote they feel like they are the only
two people in the room or world right
now our source adds ben can't stop
gushing over j.lo quote ben has been
telling jyn how unbelievably happy he is
that she is his wife feeling so lucky
it's not often you get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
i love you
i love you too it's been a whirlwind
month for the love birds they jetted off
to paris for some r and r with their
kids just days after exchanging vows at
vegas's little white wedding chapel it's
just a dream come true jlo's mom lupe
would probably agree because we're told
lupe keeps saying she always knew ben
was the one our source says she is so
happy that ben is officially part of the
family how can i tell you and while
we've been living for the couple's chic
parisian getaway our source says this
wasn't their honeymoon jen and ben had
the best time in paris exploring popular
restaurants taking casual strolls around
the city and always the fashionista j-lo
actually wanted to serve romantic and
more laid-back looks for the trip i
always have fun with fashion the
newlyweds even got to sneak in some
alone time without the kids we do our
best until mr and mrs affleck's future
wedding celebration a source tells us
this parish trip was a way for the two
to unwind quote eat relax celebrate
jen's birthday and have some time off
from work but these two superstars are
already back in the swing
[Music]
yeah to celebrate turning 53 jlo
stripped down to launch her new line of
body products as for ben he's suiting
back up literally suiting up as batman
the actor is set to reprise his role in
the upcoming aquaman sequel jason mamoa
shared this bts snap on set
[Music]
you